hello in this video we'll talk about
glycogen metabolism
glycogen is actually a polymer of
glucose
and it's a complex polysaccharide it's
also branched in this video we look at
the synthesis and the breakdown of
glycogen
so glucose gets converted
to glucose 6-phosphate with the help of
the enzyme hexokinase
now this glucose 6-phosphate eventually
forms pyruvate and atp is generated in
this process and we all know this is
glycolysis
when we have enough amount of glucose in
our body let's say after a meal our body
would generate energy out of it
but after a point of time there would be
too much of glucose and body really
don't need that much of energy so what
it would do
it would stop the process of glycolysis
and divert this glucose 6 phosphate
to create glucose one phosphate with the
help of the enzyme phosphogluco mutase
now glucose one phosphate would be
further converted into udp glucose
and this udp glucose can be attached to
a growing glycogen chain with the help
of the enzyme glycogen synthesis so this
process is known as
glycogenoglycogenesis that means
creation of glycogen
now glycogenesis
takes place when glucose level is really
high let's say after a meal when we have
taken a lot of glucose in our food
now glycogenesis is stimulated by
several hormones like insulin
so glycogen is metabolized
in liver and in the muscle
actually when we have too much of
glucose we store
that glucose for the future in format of
glycogen such that whenever it is
necessary glycogen can be broken down
and we can get the energy
so
glycogen synthesis can only take place
when there is an existing primer and
glycogen synthesis can attach
residues on these eggs growing primer
so initially a protein glycogen in which
is a 37 kilo dalton protein ensures
the polymerization happens swiftly
and then
eventually glycogen synthesis add up
more residues to form this complex
network of glycogen
the key enzyme that regulates this
process is glycogen synthesis which has
two conformations inactive and an active
conformation in the inactive
conformation it is heavily
phosphorylated at the c-terminal region
so you can clearly imagine there would
be certain kinase residues that triggers
this phosphorylation process and there
could be phosphatase residues that
triggers the de-phosphorylation reaction
and thereby activating or inactivating
this enzyme so it's like
a nice toggle switch
which allows the enzyme to get activated
or inactivated in a context dependent
fashion let's talk about the context and
the hormonal regulation brings us to the
context several hormones such as insulin
positively regulate these phosphatase
enzyme and thereby
making the glycogen synthase active by
removing the phosphate residues
now other enzymes
such as kinase can inactivate glycogen
synthesis point to be noted other
hormones such as glucagon and
epinephrine is a negative regulator of
this phosphatase enzyme whereas it is a
positive regulator for kinase enzyme so
moral of the story glucagon or
epinephrine tends to inactivate the
glycogen synthesis enzymes and
preventing glycogen synthesis pathway
now glycogen is like a fixed deposit of
glucose when we have too much of money
we store it in the bank for future this
is like our savings right so glycogen is
also stored for the future and whenever
we need energy glycogen can be broken
down in muscle and liver to generate
energy and this breakdown happens with
the help of several enzymes
and the end product of this is glucose
6-phosphate glucose 6-phosphate can then
further channelized into glycolysis
pathway to generate energy
so it's energy on demand
and this process of breaking down of
glycogen is known as glycogenolysis
in starved state body utilize glycogen
reserve to generate energy so obviously
glycogenolysis happens when we are
starving for long
site of glycogenesis is muscle and liver
and the enzymes that are required is
glycogen phosphorylase debranching
enzyme and phosphoglucomutase
in a moment we would try to understand
how these enzymes work so first of all
let's talk about the glycogen
phosphorylase which breaks down the
glycosidic linkage and free up glucose
residues in the solution
so the debra so these phosphorylase
enzymes
act on the glycogen chain and freeing up
glucose residues
glycogen phosphorylase has a pyridoxal
phosphate as a
coenzyme and there are specific residues
in the um
and which has formed a safe base with
the lysine 680 amino acid and this is
crucial for the functionality of
glycogen phosphorylase enzyme so if we
delve deep into the biochemistry we can
see the alpha 1 4 glycosidic linkage
actually mounts a nucleophilic attack on
the phosphate group in glycogen
phosphorylase and thereby breaking the
linkage and forming a transient linkage
with the enzyme later on this glucose
one phosphate which is now linked with
the glycogen phosphorylase enzyme would
be freed up
point to be noted that glycogen
phosphorylase
comes to an halt when it is four
residues away from the branch point
now at the branch point glycogen
phosphorylase would be replaced by the d
branching enzyme
d branching enzyme can cleave the branch
point because it can break down one six
glycosidic linkages
once debranching enzyme has done its job
and removing
the branch point like glucose then the
glycogen phosphorylase again can be
recruited to the linear chain and it can
do its job break down glycosidic linkage
and free up glucose
ultimately phosphogluco mutase would
convert this glucose one phosphate into
glucose 6-phosphate
so there is a quick nucleophilic attack
which fro
which
which leads to a production of glucose 1
6 bis phosphate as a transient uh
species and eventually glucose 6
phosphate is generated from glucose 1
phosphate once glucose 6 phosphate is
generated it can be channeled into
glycolysis pathway now let's take an
example in real life where glycolysis
where glycogenolysis takes place let's
say you are chased by a mad dog so if
you stop running the dog would probably
bite you so your skeletal muscle need to
contract at very high pace
so your skeletal muscle need to burn a
lot of glucose for energy but let's say
you haven't eaten in last four hours so
obviously you don't have too much of
glucose in your bloodstream
so where would your muscle get the
glucose from
actually your muscle has the reserve of
glycogen immediately there would be
signal that would break down the
glycogen into glucose that would help
you to generate atp and evade this kind
of situation and this is kind of a
flight or fight response
in these circumstances there are
hormonal regulation like epinephrine or
adrenaline you might must have heard
about adrenaline rush so adrenaline
binds to the beta adrenergic receptor on
your skeletal muscles
it leads to cyclic amp elevation which
activates protein kinase a protein
kinase a subsequently activate
phosphorylase kinase which eventually
activates glycogen phosphorylase and as
we have seen so far glycogen
phosphorylase is the key enzyme which
breakdowns glycogen into glucose so it
breaking it is breaking down glycogen
into readily active form utilizable
format of energy and thereby our muscles
could be filled and we can evade a
stressful situation
so this video kind of tells us how
glycogen metabolism
is relevant for our own physiology
so glycogen breakdown also supplies
glucose to our brain while we are
starving while we are starving we do we
have low level of blood glucose but our
brain cannot stop working because brain
need glucose for its functioning
in that circumstance
gluco i mean the glycogen from the liver
is broken down into glucose residues and
that is channelized to the brain for its
energy
so i hope this video was useful and you
get an overall picture that how glycogen
metabolism takes place and how it is
relevant for our physiological functions
so if you like this video please
please kind of support my channel in
patreon if you are indian viewer please
support me on beam upi your small
contribution even 10 rupees contribution
contribution would
create a lot of difference and it means
a lot for me
so don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can take my course in
academy using my code mp10 will give you
a 10 discount thank you